Now that we've gone through that calculation,
let me just point out one little caveat to you.
I'm going back to the scikit-learn documentation, just really quickly.
So, I've gone over to the DecisionTreeClassifier documentation here.
And I see that the splitting criteria that I used,
is actually a tunable parameter for scikit-learn.
And, in fact, as it happens the default is a metric that's called
the gini index which is another similar metric of impurity.
You can see that they also support entropy or the information game, but
this is something that you have to put in by hand.
Either one of these will work probably fine out of the box.
But I did want to mention it to you that in scikit-learn the default is
going to be something slightly different from the entropy.
But both of them should give you reasonably good results.
It's also something that would be interesting to play around with.
So let's head over to Sebastian now.
He's going to talk some about bias and variance.
And what that has to do with decision trees and
all types of supervised classifiers.